[Música]
Argentina vive su sequía más fuerte en
los últimos 40 años una temporada seca y
de altas temperaturas que también
padecen las vecinas Uruguay y chile en
marzo una ola de calor trabajo
temperaturas récord y además de causar
incendios y afectar la vida de
residentes y turistas sofocó cultivos y
ha tenido duros efectos en la economía
Argentina que ya superó la inflación del
100% para analizar este tema nos
acompaña en nuestro estudio nuestro
periodista Juan Pablo lucumí y también
se conecta con nosotros desde Argentina
el economista Gustavo nefa director de
research en finguero Gracias por estar
con nosotros Gustavo la atribución
meteorológica mundial estimó que las
exportaciones agrícolas de Argentina
este año caerán un 28% En comparación
con 2022 cuéntenos qué implica esto
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que el
país es el principal exportador de soya
en el mundo y que su
bueno Muchas gracias
el sector agropecuario representa el 65%
del ingreso de dólares en Argentina vía
exportaciones con lo cual lo que estamos
anticipando Es que este año va a ser
desastroso en materia de afluencia de
Visas con un 48% de caída esperada en
dólares ingresados por comercio exterior
esto equivale más o menos a 20.000
millones de dólares y un poco más la
caída representa 3% del pbi la caída de
la cosecha se centra en la soja y en el
maíz ya hemos visto La cosecha fina
entre diciembre y enero tener unos
resultados en materia de rendimientos
realmente muy malos y la consecuencia
Obviamente con menores exportaciones y
menores afluencia de dólares lo cual
redunda también una menor recaudación
fiscal se estima que este año también va
a haber alrededor de siete mil millones
de dólares menos de recaudación fiscal
vía derechos de exportación y
retenciones a las importaciones pero
este caso las retenciones no implican
una caída sino las los derechos a las
exportaciones que van a mermar bueno
Gustavo y le quiero dar la bienvenida a
Juan Pablo luccumí nuestro periodista
especializado en economía aquí en France
24 y que también quiere hacerle un par
de preguntas Juan Pablo bienvenido
Buenos días María Clara Buenos días
Gustavo Mi pregunta es con respecto a
pues las sequía es un problema que pues
Es evidente en Argentina que agravaría
más la crisis económica pero que otras
alternativas tendría el país hay países
por ejemplo que dependiendo a su región
a su ubicación geográfica tienen que
recurrir a otras alternativas es el caso
de Europa que debe pues tener la
importación de energía el tema de gas
pero Argentina que con un tema que pues
es medioambiental que no depende del
gobierno que otras alternativas tendría
para poder no tener no estar tan
agravado en este tema económico
bueno es una pregunta muy amplia en
realidad Argentina demasiado concentrada
en su cosecha debería empezar a
diversificar su fuente de ingresos en
este sentido existe una reserva de
petróleo que es la tercera más grande
del mundo de jlol que se llama vaca
muerta y que está explotada apenas en un
5% donde También tenemos la segunda
reserva más grande del mundo de gas de
gas también en vaca muerta que está
totalmente inexplotada esto generaría
según algunos expertos mayores Divisas
Incluso en un plazo de diez años que la
cosecha en Argentina y esto sería un un
cambio muy radical en la estructura
económica pero eso requiere inversiones
acordate que las inversiones de petróleo
minería etcétera requieren de
inversiones de largo plazo grandes
montos de inversiones y con un riesgo
país por arriba del dos mil puntos en
Argentina con un plan del fmi que a
duras cuesta podemos lograr mantener ya
hemos pedido el primer Weber y
posiblemente tengamos que pedir otro por
el tema fiscal del mes de enero que no
es la situación deseada ahora esto le
atañe también a otras economías
recordemos que este fenómeno de la niña
con altas temperaturas Está produciendo
también un dolor de cabeza en muchos
otros lugares ahora lo que se viene es
una etapa con un poco más de humedad es
cierto el niño parece irrumpir de manera
salvadora pero no así en tema de
temperaturas posiblemente este año que
va a ser seguramente más alto en
temperaturas respecto al año pasado
va a registrar una de las temperaturas
más altas de la historia estamos
hablando de uno coma cinco grados por
encima de promedio histórico y estamos
hablando de un impacto ambiental mucho
mayor Sí y precisamente como usted lo
mencionaba hay distintos países
afectados Uruguay chile como lo
mencionamos previamente pero le quiero
preguntar antes por algo Argentina y es
que el país había anunciado relajar las
restricciones a las importaciones Qué
pasará ahora con esta sequía histórica
relajar las importaciones lo veo muy
difícil en un contexto de escasez de
Divisas Argentina acaba incluso de
acordar con el femini rebajar la meta de
acumulación de reservas internacionales
que escasean arrancamos el año con seis
mil millones de dólares netas neta de
todas las deudas de los encajes del Swap
con China y Hoy estamos hablando de unos
tres mil millones esta sequía va a
grabar la situación
deberían restringirse aún más no
liberarse las importaciones Creo yo que
el cepo cambiario para la atesoramiento
de las Divisas para las personas que es
más de 200 dólares imposible de
conseguir por vía legal aquí en
Argentina con un cúmulo de impuestos de
80% o 95% si uno paga la tarjeta en
exterior con consumos se ha vuelto un
combo muy difícil El Banco Central y el
gobierno está administrando la escasez Y
esta es una situación bastante Trágica
para la Argentina que depende de sus
exportaciones recordemos que tiene
Argentina cerrado el mercado de deuda
voluntaria internacional debido a una
posibilidad de reestructurar su deuda
hacia adelante como los indican sus
creencias y muchos analistas que hablan
de que esta situación en la deuda
externa podría volver a generar un
problema hacia adelante dentro de cuatro
o cinco años Gustavo precisamente usted
menciona acerca del plan del fmi otro de
los requisitos que ha dado es acerca de
la reducción fiscal y en estos panoramas
Entonces el gobierno empieza a hacer
inversión de las personas que necesitan
Pues de estas ayudas pero como cumplir
con esa reducción fiscal en medio de
esta crisis brevemente por favor
muy difícil y muy fácil la respuesta no
lo va a hacer es imposible
Argentina tiene acordado un déficit
fiscal el año pasado fue del dos coma
cinco por ciento lo logró pateando
muchos vencimientos de siembra de enero
enero representó un récord de de déficit
fiscal primario y con los intereses
llegó a más de 500 mil millones de pesos
es una locura
lo que veo es que este año la meta de
uno coma nueve por ciento en relación al
pbi y déficit primario va a ser muy
difícil de cumplir en medio de un año
electoral primer tema segundo la sequía
que redunda en los siete mil millones de
dólares menos de recaudación estimados y
obviamente con la carga de los intereses
en aumento muchas de la deuda en pesos
está indexada con lo cual esto es muy
difícil de contener una en una
expectativa de inflación de
103,5% para este año Ese es el consenso
analista del Rem del Banco Central del
mes de febrero conocido a comienzo de
mes Gustavo e Gracias por estar con
nosotros y por este completo panorama
muchas gracias a ustedes y Gracias
también a ustedes Juan Pablo y por estar
con nosotros ustedes sigan conectados a
France 24 porque en segundos tenemos más
información internacional
[Música]